♪ Started my life was kind of rough ♪
♪ I had an uphill battle ♪
♪ The doctor sat my parents down ♪
♪ And said my life was fragile ♪
♪ Respecting is the game ♪
♪ And Gary Vee the name ♪
♪ Just put your head down ♪
♪ Do the work and
everything would change ♪
♪ Sip the tea, help the fields ♪
♪ Yeah, that's what I wanted ♪
♪ Being patient held a
tricky if I'm being honest ♪
♪ Tea with GaryVee, put
your positivity, yeah ♪
- It's that kind of swirl
It's that kind of,
it's that signature at
the end kind of shit.
What's good everybody,
it's tea time with V time.
9:02, May 20th.
We're in it now.
We are fully in quarantine now.
Now it's real life,
now regular life is weird.
Hope everybody's super well,
really appreciate being on with me.
Just great show yesterday,
let's see if we can match it.
Dustin on the ones and twos,
Dustin how are you, my friend?
- Excellent.
Anything interesting?
- I'm trying to see if the
LinkedIn comments are--
- Oh yes, LinkedIn.
Big shout out to LinkedIn.
I know LinkedIn update,
I don't see the comments in here.
- I don't see them either.
- It looks like a huge fail
once again for the Dust.
- Wait, no, no, no, no, no.
You said (laughing), yeah.
- Oh, there they are.
There we go.
To link the first LinkedIn
comment I've seen.
Big shoutout to Christopher Gonzales.
What is up LinkedIn?
You are in,
that was a Periscope.
There we go.
(Dustin laughing)
Gonzales doesn't have a,
lot of LinkedIns may not have logos.
Oh, there she is.
Ann Marie Lavelle, good
morning, good morning.
LinkedIn is now in the
building on the public chats.
I'm excited about that.
Then we've got Twitch with Matt Shull,
Facebook, Instagram.
Before we get into this, please.
Oh, Instagram big shout out to Instagram
because you know we go ghetto with it
because it doesn't tap
what stream you are this platform we use,
which is remarkable,
but (mumbles) I think holds it up,
so big shout out to everybody
on Instagram, I love you.
So now we're live on LinkedIn, Twitch,
Facebook, Twitter and YouTube.
All comments enabled, Instagram
is the only live place we're
at where the comments
are not enabled, correct?
- Yep.
- All right.
Let's get him to show Rudy from LinkedIn.
Look at the LinkedIn fan.
Let's get the LinkedIn,
everybody LinkedIn share this,
share this live please.
Let's get the LinkedIn share volume going.
Let's get in the share
mode everybody in general.
All right, let's get this going.
Ric and Thadeus, what's good?
- How you doing?
- Hey, what's going on Gary?
- Good morning.
- Good morning to you gentlemen.
Thanks for being on.
- Thanks for having us.
- Definitely.
- What's cooking?
- We started making beats
and seven or more online
back in 2011,
kind of just building a fan base,
growing a solid income.
And over the years we started
to become one of the top
sellers online landing
some placements eventually with Tiara Wag,
Bad Bunny, Juice World.
And through that we got
out there solid base,
of probably 20, 30,000
customers over the years
and wanted to add something to them.
What would you recommend the new artists
do in terms of non-music content?
- Non music?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I think,
I can't believe you guys
just brought this up.
Literally we're chopping up a business
at Vayner Land last night.
We were talking about artists
and as you two know me,
my boy and a lot of us,
we spent a lot of time in the space,
but we're not looking to start a label
or go into management,
but we did get into this
conversation of like how
multi-dimensional artists are
and need to be to really take
it to the next level.
And I think any artist
in the world that can,
that can do other shit needs to.
- Right.
- Right?
Like if you're capable
of being funny on TikTok.
If you're a supermodel-looking person,
if you're funny and you can do Instagram,
if you can do a podcast.
I mean, look at Joe button, right?
Like his podcast absolutely
gives him unlimited leverage,
if he was in the mood to drop
a project, it would matter.
Right?
Look at Khaled.
Khaled's made hundreds
of millions of dollars
on the back of a five-day
execution on Snapchat.
So of course, of course.
I mean, and that's something
we've always enamored
and put on a pedestal.
Jlo, Beyonce, people that
could do more, right?
People that could do more.
So yeah.
I mean, I actually would argue
the debate in 20 years will be,
should any artists just do music?
It's almost like the reverse,
the internet just creates
obnoxious levels of opportunity.
You guys lived it, I lived it.
Like people don't get it.
You look at Latin Trap, you
look at Bad Bunny Balvin,
Satchel, that whole movement, right?
It doesn't happen without the internet.
- Right, that's true.
- I mean the record lately,
like MTV didn't want to
play Michael Jackson.
(laughing)
Because you know, racism,
subjective calls, I'll give
you another classic one.
The person that ran CBS
or whatever the network,
Gilligan's Island was on,
his wife loved some show
that nobody gave a fuck about.
They canceled it.
When they unveiled the fall schedule
in 1958 or '62 or whatever
the fuck that was,
she went ham and her fucking husband
kicked out Gilligan's Island
and put her bullshit show in.
That is the reason there
aren't a hundred more episodes
of Gilligan's Island.
- Crazy.
- That's wild.
That doesn't happen in the internet.
We can all do, everybody
watching this morning can do
and should.
And now the artists big
shout out to Pharell,
by making nerd culture or other,
big shout out to fucking Andre 3000,
you know the culture now
lets you be anything.
You want to be into
fucking some dorky shit
that was unacceptable in 1994.
Now you can do anything
which then means you
could do anything, right?
Like Tyler The Creator, Pharell,
Lil Yachty, that shit
doesn't fly in 1996 hip hop,
it was narrow.
Now you could do anything.
So if you're silly on TikTok
but you fucking talk hard lyrics
from the South side of Atlanta on Spotify,
you can actually get away with that shit.
- Yeah, you can.
- So that's the answer.
- All right man, thank you.
- I wish you guys all the best, take care.
Childish Gambino, that
was a great shout out,
that's another great call.
Let's keep it going.
Hi Carey.
- Hi Gary.
I'm Carey Balogh from New Jersey.
- I love that.
What part of Jersey?
- I'm in (mumbles) New Jersey.
- Great part of New Jersey, love it.
- I'm so excited to be here.
I've been following you for
a long time, so thank you--
- Thank you.
- for having me.
So I'll get to it.
So I am the Chief Executive
Groupie of Brand Groupies,
we're a full service
social media and PR agency
based in Redbank and a little backstory,
I was PR director for many
corporate fashion brands
in the city then I became an entrepreneur.
I had a children's rock
and roll team play space
in Williamsburg, Brooklyn
then moved back to New
Jersey to raise my family
and started Brand Groupie.
So passionate about entrepreneurs,
small business owners.
And I did everything I
could Gary for four years
to help small business owners,
mastermind groups, start
a podcast because of you,
strategy sessions, websites.
But after four years I was
still alone with freelancers
and so this year I made
the decision to scale
and focus primarily on B2B
service brands and AEC industry.
So 20 to $30 million
companies and just focused
on PR and social so I hired
a VP of public relations.
Amazing.
However, I am doing all the social myself
and my question to you is in 2020,
where should I focus my time?
I want to be like 10 steps
ahead of my (mumbles).
- LinkedIn.
- LinkedIn?
Okay.
- And I mean like obsessively.
Especially, I mean, if
you're going after 20,
$30 million a year B2B players,
you know, what's going to happen.
You've been around the block for 4 years.
They're going to look for business results
and as fun as like making five
TikTok videos is going to be,
that's not going to lead
to a lot of business
for that business in comparison
to a monster understanding,
best in class of LinkedIn.
- Yeah.
- That's the game.
Like you have to be the best at the ads,
you have to be the best at the content,
you have to be the best at
understanding who the influencers
on LinkedIn are and how you
can do business with them.
You have to understand every nuance,
every comment, comment culture,
like back to the thank you economy
sort of like all five of
my books kind of play out,
it's jab, jab, right hook
and the thank you economy and crush it
because you've got to
convince all your clients,
either them or somebody
that works for them needs
to be the face.
And you got to do a podcast
and put out content,
but I would say 90% of your energy,
based on who you're targeting,
needs to be on LinkedIn.
90.
- Okay.
And should I just continue to grind myself
or should I hire anyone right now?
- I mean, look, if you can
afford it, if you can afford it,
you can absolutely go that route.
But if you're still in that early stage,
which I think you are,
and plus I'd love for
you to really know it,
like really know it.
Like the thing that separates
me from everybody else
is I'm an actual practitioner
against the people I compete against.
The CEOs of big agencies
don't even fucking
have a TikTok account
or an Instagram account,
don't even have one.
And so they're not making content,
they're not living that life.
And so that's the reality of it.
- Okay.
All right.
So I'll go deeper in LinkedIn.
Thank you so much, Gary.
- You're welcome.
- Okay, thank you.
My dad's got some landscaping
going on here (mumbles).
- I was about to ask what is that noise?
- It's noise Dustin.
Real life happens around here.
Social distancing landscaping for pops.
All right, let's keep it going.
- Gary, what's up man?
- What's good, Dave?
- Good man. I'm doing well.
So first I just got to say thank you, man.
Like I know you hear that a lot
but like for real, for real.
Like a lot of stuff that
you've put out books,
the content deck like
completely changed my business
and helped me help a lot of people,
which will kind of make clear my question.
So for real, thank you.
- Happy to do it brother.
- But yeah, man, it's crazy.
You were talking about the
Humanity Footprint yesterday.
Like that's what my
question is kind of about
and that's pretty much
where I started my business
so can I give you like
a little bit of context?
'Cause it's kind of a big situation.
So my whole life has been in
the sport of gymnastics, right?
I've competed, I'm a coach,
I went to physical therapy school
and I just pretty much
spent all my time working
as a medical provider and
also as a coach, right?
So 2013, I started an
online educational business
because the sport just
desperately needs help
for new ideas and working
in the medical field
it's like important that people know
what the new science is and stuff.
So I really just did it
because I wanted to help people
because like a lot of kids
in the sport get hurt,
or various injuries.
Like there's a lot of concerns
about like pushing young kids
for like their Olympic dream
and college scholarships
and stuff.
So yeah, it just started
like kind of as a fun thing
and it blew up because of again,
like the content model
helped me get more material.
I'm not a businessman, I'm not a marketer.
I'm a practitioner in physical therapy,
that's what I'm good at so--
- Talk to me about soft tissue.
- Yeah, man. So, all right.
I had this at the end of
my things as a thank you
but when I texted my question in,
my shit is like back pain, shoulder pain,
like that's what I'm good at.
So, the offer's on the table,
if you ever want help with your back,
like I'm more than happy to
do it, no strings attached,
but soft tissue is one of
the most important things.
There's a couple other things that are--
- Super underrated, right?
- For real, yeah.
I think like a lot of people don't realize
it's one of those things
that like creeps up on you
and like you don't realize it's a problem
and then it's a problem.
- And you don't even
realize it's happening.
- Exactly, yeah.
So a lot of people--
- Until you actually go at it,
"Whoa!
"Why does that hurt so much?"
- Yeah, for sure.
So there's stuff between like,
soft tissue is really important--
- What else do you love?
- So changing up your
movement is super important.
Sitting is not bad for you,
it's just reversing
like what you're doing.
Like laying on your stomach
is really important for awhile
if you sit all day, like
I used to blow up my back
'cause I would read a lot.
And so laying on your stomach
for a couple of emails,
or like doing some backbends and stuff.
- And are you also like
a personal trainer?
- Yeah. So I'm a gymnastics coach,
a strength conditioning coach
and I have my doctorate
in physical therapy
and I'm a sports (mumbles)
qualified therapist, yeah.
- So one thing that's been
running through my mind,
I'm in love with what's going on
with my situation right now.
I had Mike (mumbles) for two years
then I joined him for three years,
then I had Mike again.
But I do think about like man,
I should probably start to
get to know a person or two
in case Mike,
like would you ever live
with me for a year or two?
- Probably not live with
because I got a ton of
stuff going on on my own--
- Totally get it.
- but we just built the
telehealth infrastructure at our--
- I don't give a fuck.
- really big--
- No, I need living.
- Yeah, no--
- You keep doing your thing.
All right, go into your question.
- Couldn't live with you but yeah
so long story short is
I've worked all three jobs
for seven years
just like going hard because
it's just like a rare opportunity
to help a lot of people, you know?
And so I feel like the sport
is changing and I want to kind
of capitalize on that.
And so things were going
well for four years,
grew real awesome but then in 2016,
I don't know if you know about this,
but we had like the biggest
scandal in history, yeah.
- Right, the mission at (mumbles) shit?
- Yeah.
With the doctor and all that stuff.
So the whole world got tipped
on its head and it was awful.
And it was like it cut real deep for me
and a lot of my friends
because I coach a lot of young athletes
and I'm a medical (mumbles)
I work with these athletes.
So I was lucky that the
work that I had done put me
in a position where like
here in the country,
international, like a lot of
people like snap of a finger,
like 10,000 eyeballs on
me asking if I could help.
And I had been putting
up tons of free content
because I kind of follow what you believe.
And we do monetize, I
have like some courses
and set up an online membership group
but it's always been like bare minimum
just to do the right thing for me.
- No shit.
- And so it happened and turned over
and like now it's like
a huge thing is like,
everyone's changing,
there's a lot of abuse,
like scandals that are going
on now they're resolving.
There's so many good people
that want to do the right thing
but don't have information.
So that's where I feel
like my humanity footprint
is to like make a dent
in that for the positive
and so I've always had this question
but it's more now because of
like the severity of what's
changing is what's the balance between,
I want to give it all away for free
'cause I don't pull
money from the business,
I live off my physical therapy
career and my coaching career
and like just live real boring
versus like holding the money,
selling the content that I can
use that to like hire people
or like--
- Both are fine.
I know that I sometimes
over-demonize selling content
but it's because so many
people sell bad content
and even worse so many people sell content
that they rip off from the
internet somewhere else
and they just try to do
funnels and do marketing.
If your intent is clearly good,
like I might decide to
sell content one day
'cause I feel great about it.
It's don't sell something
you don't believe in.
- Yeah.
- And also recognize
don't be mad at the world
when they're not buying your shit
when they can go Google it.
- Totally, yeah.
- So this makes sense?
- Yeah.
I guess to follow up,
it's more like on the
actual tactics of like,
if I do hold onto money,
which I'm fine with,
and I don't mind charging
for like consulting services
or like my physical therapy
services we charge for.
But like when I have money,
like do I put it into like hiring people?
I did it all for myself for six years
then I hired somebody last
year just to go bigger.
But it's more like into
finances of that versus like,
if I give away the information
like, and it's all out there,
like it's clearly going to
start to like chip away at my
bottom line and stuff.
And so I struggle--
- No, it's not.
Because it's going to lead to leverage
which may turn you into
monetizing it in a different way.
- Yeah.
- If the world loves you for
giving away great information,
and back to like soft tissue,
if you decide to come out
with your own rolling ball
with your beautiful bald head on it,
you're gonna make more
money on that fucking ball,
than you're going to make
on the fucking information.
- Yeah.
And what are your thoughts
on like giving away content
and then monetizing just
consulting services.
I thought about that.
- You're obsessed with that.
- Yeah. Would that be a better option?
'Cause I've thought about dissolving my,
like the medical courses?
You kind of need to have
those live or in person
'cause it's like a safety thing,
you have to know how to treat (mumbles).
- Of course.
- But like on my coaching education group,
I could just give everything
away for free and be like,
all right, if you want to do,
like a university wants me to come in
or like a country wants
me to fly over and do it.
I could do that but then
I struggle with like--
- Well, it's short and long term, right?
It's also against how you
want to make your money.
- Yeah.
- There's no right answer to this.
There's what's right for you.
- Okay.
- Honestly, which is liberating, right?
- Yeah.
- But you also have to be good at it.
You might be way, way, way
better at doing consulting
and personal and then speaking
and maybe creating a roller product,
you know that stick that
bends, the white stick?
Again, I think there's
a lot of opportunity,
back to like I'm not kidding.
If you're so great,
which I kind of weirdly think you are,
I literally just offered you
like the biggest thing in
my world around fitness
on intuition.
- Thank you, yeah.
- I mean, I think you could make
a hundred thousand dollars a year on a mat
that people lay down and
lay on their stomach on.
- Yeah.
- It's kind of like me with wine.
People are going to buy a mat anyway.
- Yeah.
- And if you're the guy to give (mumbles)
Dave, you drink wine, tell
the truth now, don't lie.
- So I don't drink a lot of wine
but I did buy empathy
and give it to my mom.
- I love you.
That's the answer, right?
Like for me all these fuck faces
that are watching right now,
the people that come here every
day for the last five years
get free content in perpetuity.
And yet still go to a BevMo
or a Benny's or an HEB or a
Costco or a Total Wine,
or go to wine.com and buy
their wine, that's devastating.
I want to break their face,
cue the Wine Text URL Dustin.
But so many more than
those people that somehow
have not clicked yet to like,
"Wait, I'm buying wine anyway,
"why wouldn't I buy it from the person
"that's bringing me the
most value the world
"for free?"
- Yeah.
- And so, but you have
to have the stomach,
like Dustin put it back up.
(Dave laughing)
But Dave, you have to have the stomach
for people to let you down.
- Yeah.
- Like I know as I'm
reading all these comments,
people that have literally
taken my stuff and made money
and obviously Texas, Michigan,
under 21 outside of U.S.,
you're all excluded.
But there's people right now
that are like, "Oh shit,"
like genuinely it just hit them finally.
Even though they've watched
for 60 days here, they're like,
"Right, why.
"Why would I buy from wine.com?
"Why would I buy a total wine?"
Like "Why in the world
would I not buy from Gary?"
And the best part is I've had
Wine Library the whole time.
The reason I'm pushing
Wine Text so hard is
'cause it's such a good deal.
- Yeah.
- And you can do the same thing.
You could make such a good
product that you believe in
and all that free content you
put out led to all of them
buying from you that way.
- Yeah.
Yeah, that makes sense.
And I guess the last thing
that I'll let you go is
like the only thing that works
really well in our world is,
I don't know if you have
this on the media side,
is like people can get the information
but they want to pay you
to see how you apply it.
They want to see you treat people,
they want to see you
actually coach people.
So I feel like that probably is like,
that would sit the most well with me
is like here just it is for free,
if you want to actually get my opinion,
that's cool.
- Love it.
You got it, Dave.
- Thanks man.
Two things real quick.
A great question,
what happened to Yummy Text,
Yummy Text, throw up Yummy Text and Texts,
I know we don't have a logo for it.
Because of way, with COVID and everything,
we were like on the verge of
fully launching Yummy Text,
but Yummy Text is in beta still.
And with food and all this,
we just kind of held off
but as soon as we kind of get back
to some sort of normality.
So Yummy Text is for
food, Texas, Michigan,
here's your chance sign up for that.
But real quick, don't sign up
for Yummy Text or Wine Text
unless you completely
are going to buy from it
because it costs money to send a text.
So everybody who just signed
up for Wine Text just now,
cause they felt guilty,
but you're not going to
buy wine, unsubscribe.
It's super fine.
I only want people that
buy wine to sign up for it,
you know?
All right.
But you should definitely
sign up for Wine Text.
It's a fucking crazy deal.
And today we're selling a $70 wine for 30.
A big time one.
Everyone's selling for 70,
we're selling the same for 30.
Yesterday we sold a $30 Rose like,
it's just fucking amazing.
Anyway, nonetheless, let's keep it going.
Yes, Colorado is in Lauren,
Alex, what's good?
- Oh my gosh, hi.
- Hi, how are you?
- Good.
Thank you so much for having me here.
I'm really excited.
- It's great to have you Alex.
- I have my mom right here.
- That's what's up.
Hi.
What's her name?
- Hello.
- (mumbles).
- (mumbles), so nice to meet you.
- Nice meeting you too.
- Yeah, I really like
your Trash Talk show,
just saying I really like it.
I appreciate it.
Have you gone garage saling yet?
- I'm planning to do that
in the summer with my mom.
- I love it.
Once we get back to some
normalcy, I love it.
- Yeah.
- What can I answer for you, bro?
- Yeah, I'm gonna like
give a little context
about my question and stuff.
- Go ahead.
- And it's about TikTok.
I have two questions.
I started TikTok like a year ago.
I didn't really like,
I wasn't really that like
passionate about it like long ago
and that long ago and my
siblings like started it
so I just got it for
fun, things like that.
- Yep.
- And I have ADHD and it's like,
it comes with like a hard
time controlling my emotions
and things like that.
Especially with my like medication.
It's like a side effect
and things like that.
But like TikTok,
like usually I just go through it
when I'm having like a bad day
and it like helps me and
it changes my whole mood.
- That makes me so happy, bro.
- And when I like noticed
that a few months ago,
I noticed that I can do
that for like people too.
And it like made me really happy.
So then I just kept
making videos every day
and like one comment that
I got in my video said
like it made their night and I was like
(Gary laughing) so happy.
- I love that. I love you for that.
- Yeah.
I realized that I could
like do that for people.
But like--
- It's such a special gift,
that's super precious
bro, I'm proud of you.
- Yeah.
And then like the hard time
controlling my emotions
and stuff like when I'm sad, I'm sad.
But it's hard to like get hate comments
'cause I got like hate
around my old friends
that like used to be my friends.
- Understood.
- Yeah.
But--
- Alex, can I tell you
something about that?
- Yeah.
- When people leave hate on the internet,
it means that they're hurting.
You're quote unquote old friends,
it just means that
they're hurting inside too
and the manifestation of
their own internal pain
is being left in your comments.
- Oh, that's actually, yeah.
- You see where I'm going?
- Mm-hmm (affirmative).
- Instead of feeling bad for yourself
when somebody leaves hate,
you need to feel bad for them.
Like compassion, like empathy,
like instead of being like hurt by them
and being mad at them,
you need to say, "Why did Havier,"
Or "Why did Rick do that?"
And you say, "Damn, he's in a bad spot."
Anybody who puts bad into the world
is actually hurting
really bad inside, bro.
- That's true.
'Cause why else would they do it then?
- That's right.
They're trying to bring somebody else down
because they're down.
Meanwhile, you got nothing but sweetness
and love in your heart,
which is why you're
trying to bring people up.
- Yeah.
- Can I ask you this
huge important question?
Why is your mom's tea mug so huge?
- (mom laughing) 'cause
she living the mug life.
- Let's go mug life!
That's what I was hoping you would say.
Let's go my guy.
That's what I fuck with.
Good shit, Alex.
You do watch Trash Talk. I love that.
- But yeah, I have one more question.
- Go ahead.
- So I have like friends, right?
That like are on TikTok too
and like at least three of them have like,
they like do basically the
same content that I put out.
- Okay.
- And they get like a
different response, you know?
- More comments?
More followers?
Less?
Worse?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like they have like 100K and everything
and I'm having a hard
time comparing myself.
- Yeah, Alex I promise
you something right now.
You wanna limit the
amount of time you're sad?
Let me promise you something right now,
giving a fuck about anybody else's account
is the worst move in the world.
- All right.
- Bro, they're happy, be happy for them.
You're a kind kid.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
I'm happy for them--
- Stop, stop, stop.
No, no, no comma, no comma.
Like I'm happy for them,
damn, I'm sad for me.
I wanna be there.
It needs to be, I'm happy for them,
exclamation point.
- Okay, yeah.
- You got me?
Bro, listen to me.
I'm gonna tell you something
that I hope you watch over and over.
There is nothing I'm more confident about
than you're going to win in life.
Bro, I see it right through you.
- I appreciate that.
- You got nothing but good.
- Thank you so much.
- You just have to be patient and believe.
Don't worry about comparing.
And by the way, I don't want to pry into,
this gets into more family stuff with you
and what you're talking about,
but I promise you, your
thing is your gift,
not your fucking weakness.
- Thanks.
- That energy leads to creativity, bro.
I'm sure I have it.
I just didn't grow up in the system
when they used to test this (mumbles).
- Yeah.
- You understand?
You have a gift, bro.
If you do anything from this
video you take in your mind
and you shift this thing,
we all get sad, we all get happy.
But I promise you if don't
compare and if you feel bad
for people that are
like putting bad on you,
if you feel compassionate
and empathetic for them,
like bro, you're going to win, bro.
- I appreciate that.
- You've got the ingredients,
now you just got to cook it.
- Yeah.
- You understand?
Alex, I expect you to tag me
on your first Trash Talk
TikTok video once this world
open up.
- Yeah, deal.
- Bet.
- Gary.
- Yes dear.
- I just want to say something.
- Please.
- So I am so happy that
I was able to find you
and I introduced Alex to you.
I kept sending him like
clips and stuff about you
and he finally got into it.
And you know sometimes kids and moms,
they don't want to listen to
what their mom really says,
'cause I've been telling him
the same thing that you say,
'cause I'm learning from you.
- Of course,
- Sometimes it takes
somebody else to come in
and get them, you know like click
and I really am very
happy that I found you
so I can help him through you.
- If I told you how emotional
that just made me in my soul,
I thank you so much for saying that.
You don't even know what that means to me.
Thank you.
Alex, listen to me.
We're going to be friends.
You need to stay the course.
I can't wait to be friends with you
once you don't have to go
to school all the time.
Like please do me a favor.
Don't just make this a one moment thing.
Take what I sent you and
put it into your soul.
When people are leaving
bad comments or people
are talking shit in real
life, they're in a bad place.
You need to be compassionate.
When other people are winning,
you need to be happy for them.
Neither your friends that are
winning or your old friends
that are tearing you down,
neither one of those people have anything
to do with your life.
You got a great mom,
you got a great family,
you got a great head of
hair, you're cute as fuck.
You gotta figure it out, bro.
We got this.
- Awesome.
And you have to get me in the show too,
I have some stuff that
I want to talk about.
- All right, talk to Dustin.
He'll get you in mom.
- Okay, we love you.
- Love you back.
Take care everyone.
Bye bye.
- Thank you so much.
- Love this shit.
People spending all their time
like focusing on what's bad in the world.
And then you have that seven minutes.
All right, let's get it going.
Nick.
- Gary, what's up man?
- It's always tough to follow the kid.
- I know it is.
It's hard not to compare yourself in that
you're that young and stuff too.
There's so much societal
pressure and stuff.
- Well, it's hard to not
compare yourself at 53.
- I compare myself to 30 and
now, so you know, I get it.
It's just so hard when
you're surrounded by that.
But I just want to say
you're an absolute legend.
Honestly, the way of your words,
as you can tell, even with them,
it just means much to a lot
of people and you help so much
with us going through this pandemic,
outside of this, everything
like I've been following
you for a long time.
This is honestly an honor so--
- Thank you brother.
- I appreciate it.
- I'll give you a small background.
I've live in Portland, Oregon.
I'm originally from
Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
I'm currently doing PPC
marketing at the moment.
Right after high school,
I ended up going to college
actually for computer science
and then graphic design.
And then I changed my major again.
I ended up dropping out
after a couple of years
because honestly I just went
because my mom wanted me to
and I wanted to make her proud.
- So you only (mumbles) to college
and fucking played video
games and fucking gambled
and went to the track and
fucking went garage sales
and Toys "R" Us paid off.
I paid off every kid in Toys "R" Us
and I went to 10 different Toys "R" Us
in the Boston, new in Needham,
like area and literally
paid off all the employees
to keep all the starting lineups
and Star Wars and Power Ranger
and Spice Girl figures in the back.
And then I would do like
literally all day when I was
supposed to be in class would
drive around and pick up all
the toys that they kept in the
back for me that I would then
sell on early eBay for
like 80 bucks a figure
when I would buy it for $7.99.
- That's crazy.
Yeah, I did photography actually
as a part time thing to kind of
get myself through and whatnot.
But to be honest with you,
I didn't know what I wanted to do.
It was photography, graphic design.
- Of course.
- Science stuff like that.
- You were a creative kid
to try and figure it out.
I get it.
- So I went into retail
management right after that
'Cause I did retail before that.
So I went into the more kind
of management side of it
and then went into IT.
That's what I thought I wanted to do it,
turns out I don't like looking
at this computer screen
24/7 and my eyeballs drying out
and just coding and doing all that stuff.
So I kind of put the things
together where I love people,
I love interacting, I love helping
and I love analytics and stuff.
So I was like marketing.
That's what I want to do.
- Yeah, man.
If you love math and art and people,
you're fucking, you got the juice.
- Exactly.
So with that said,
I was able to kind of get an
entry level PPC marketing job
and everything that
didn't require a degree.
And I wanted my foot in
that I wanted to make sure,
you know, not only this is
for sure what I wanna do
but really get an idea of
this is my career pathway.
- I apologize, Nick.
Hey Dustin.
- Yup.
- Can you cue up the full Joe Rogan clip
where I even predict how
much money it's gonna go for?
- I can pull it from our Twitter, I think.
- And then like play
it in here at the end?
Can we like queue it up?
- Yeah, I'll see.
I'll start working on that.
- All right, go ahead Nick.
I apologize.
Just had a thought.
- No, you're good.
That's crazy by the way,
it's gotta be an enormous amount of money
it's gonna take to go over there.
- It's being reported it's
a hundred million and there's an interview
I gave last year where
I literally threw out
that exact number.
- No way.
Yeah I--
- Anyway, keep going.
- So anyways, doing PPC marketing,
been doing it for three years.
I love my company.
Honestly, the culture of the
CEO's are great and stuff,
but what I've realized doing
just the PPC end of everything
is I wanted to do more and I want
to help these small businesses
'cause I do businesses anywhere from
a staff of one where it's
just the owner to 50.
So it's rather than just the ground up
where people that really
are just kind of starting and stuff.
And what I've realized is
that even though I'm their PPC
marketing person, they need a lot more.
They need a lot more ideas on
brand, identity, messaging.
Where do I go from here?
What do I do for my organic
content and stuff like that.
I've taught myself a lot of
things outside of just kind of
the Google ad side of things too.
- You're multi-dimensional
and you don't want to be
pigeonholed and either you have
to do it by yourself or you
have to expand with the New York.
- Right, exactly.
And the problem is is
that we have departments
for every type of medium and stuff.
- Right.
So Renaissance man,
the Swiss army knife doesn't fit the mold
of the infrastructure.
- Yeah.
And I wanna grow at this
point and I am moving up,
I'm doing an interim lead
thing right now and stuff
and I really appreciate
my job and everything,
but it doesn't spark the fire in me like
that I have to really go above
and beyond for businesses
and be able to do a lot more.
So I haven't actually
a couple of scenarios
I wanna run by you.
One, I actually have a
pretty good relationship
with the CEO and he sees a lot in me
that he sees in himself and stuff.
And what I want to do
essentially is kind of pitch him
because he's created the
jobs within our organization.
- Yes, next.
It's gonna work.
On the record, it's gonna work.
On the record it's gonna work.
Based on the culture,
I want to meet this CEO, like he sat down.
He (mumbles)
- Yeah.
- He sounds fucking awesome.
Great culture making up jobs,
he sounds like fucking like has a lot of
like same points of view I have.
I like him.
- I think you would get along with him.
I'll send you the information that Dustin
and I'm on private right
now, but I'll send it over.
- Yeah, yeah.
I think first go have that pitch
because maybe he turns into a dragon
and then I don't want to be his friend.
- He's a good guy.
- Clearly.
- The second option is,
I think this is the
goal of a lot of people
that once worked for an agency
is I want to do all
marketing for one company.
I wanna be like a marketing
director for one company
or brand or a certain industry.
Even like I do industries
anywhere from like retail
to service, to CNC machines
and stuff like that.
And some of it, I had like
a true passion for it.
It's just like--
- Would you move?
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Nick, send me an email.
A real one.
- Okay. Yeah.
- Dustin will take care of it.
- Dude, if you actually,
I'm taking everything back.
If you have to write down
gary@vaynermedia.com,
I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
- I'm actually writing down,
just kind of snippets and stuff for myself
from the first scenario, second scenario.
I know. Yeah.
- And plus everybody learns differently.
Like I can't write down anything.
I'm actually fascinated by the process
of writing things down.
I think it's kind of cool.
I repeat it in my head
without even moving my lips
and that's how I remember things.
- Yeah.
- But if I wrote it down, I'd be dead.
- I'm gonna watch this
20 times over honestly.
But for some reason it's a thing
where you write it down too.
- Nick, you don't even need
to watch this 20 times over.
Let me recap it for you.
Yes.
Like literally write
on your pad right now.
Capital Y, capital E, capital S.
That's it brother.
That is maybe what I'm going to end up
putting on my gravestone.
Like what I'm teaching and
what I'm trying to convey
is 98% of people watching
this right now live in no
and I live in yes.
- Yeah.
- You're so uncomfortably
obviously talented.
I mean it.
- Thank you.
- I think I want you to
work for VaynerMedia.
Or there's 30 different jobs
I can put you in if you
want to go brand side.
But like
- Yeah.
Like you just need to believe in yes.
The answer is yes to everything.
And then when it's yes, talk
to the boss and create a job.
Yes, start my own thing.
Yes, go brand side.
Literally, and I'm not kidding,
you're gonna love this.
Flip a fucking coin or throw a dart
because you'll never know the alternative.
All three are good.
Let me give you an example.
Let's just play this out
'cause it's gonna help so many people.
You're at a crossroads right now
and it's not even a
one-dimensional crossroads.
It's like a three-legged stool.
Do I triple down on where I'm at?
Things are good.
Go talk the boss and create this cool role
and fucking build?
Do I take Gary up on it
(mumbles) go to Vayner.
Do I have Gary help me become
the digital brand director
at Bojangles 'cause he sits on the board
and I move to North Carolina.
Let's play it out.
Let's say, when you get to heaven,
this is my dream of heaven.
That it can show you every scenario
of how things would have played out.
And what you ended up doing was you came
and worked with me and that worked.
You worked on team Gary for three years,
it built up your profile.
You felt you met the, are you married?
- No, I'm single.
- Good.
You found the love of your life,
you had a great family,
you're in the Jersey suburb.
Then you take that platform.
Let's go even crazier.
Like I did with Nate and Trout.
I bring you into a brand,
six years later now you
own 5% of a coffee brand.
You're the CMO, we're doing it.
And now we sell it to
Nestle for $200 million.
And you're only 46 years old.
But when you fly to
Nestle to close the deal,
as we're doing the celebratory dinner,
you choke on a chicken bone and you die,
Right?
That's literally how I think about life.
You could have been to Bojangles,
all the shit I said for the
first 90% of that story,
wasn't as good.
You did great.
You made 150,000 a year,
you loved Charlotte.
It was good.
You also find another love of your life.
And you live this great
life and he lived to 92
and have four great
grandchildren and this and that
and the other thing.
You just don't know.
- Yeah.
And I just don't want to live my life
with any type of regret.
Like at the same time, I'm
not wasting my time too
'cause I'm learning so much
because I do connect with
these organizations within
our overall umbrella.
We learn a lot more about
SEO website, Facebook,
all that, so--
- You're winning.
You just need to make
decisions and jump in
and not look back and
just do that forever.
- Yeah.
I think my biggest hurdle,
just kind of looking at things
and I've dabbled with it,
I haven't really explored a lot,
is a lot of those bigger marketing roles
and stuff says degree required
and like experiencing--
- Dude, you're too good.
Like just reach out and
say, I don't have it.
Many are going to say yes.
And duly required is going
to go away and fuck them.
- Yeah.
One little thing too is, one of the many--
- And for example, they may
not require it at Vayner
as we continue to dominate more firms
are going to do that.
Because they're going to copy.
- How's Rokkr doing with
e-sports and everything?
I ask that because that's another industry
that I'm interested in just in general.
And I haven't heard.
- Yeah, I mean Call of Duty
League is going really well.
Obviously I'm quite enjoying
being a minority owner
of a e-sports team, Minnesota Rokkr,
make sure you follow them on all socials,
R-O-K-K-R.
It's going really well.
It's the first year we
were doing in-person events
so that we have to do some adjustments,
but the reality is I'm learning a lot
and it's a great space.
I'm really into e-sports.
- That's good to hear Gary,
thank you for everything.
I mean it's yes in my head
but sometimes it's just
like the more and more
where it's just you need
to hear from the game,
Gary himself.
- No, no, you're gonna appreciate this.
You, like many people 30 and above,
put a degree on a pedestal,
grew up in an era where it meant something
and you have an insecurity
around not having it.
And I'm trying to pull
that shit off your chest.
When I tell you it means
zero, it means zero.
- Yeah.
If I get my foot in the door
and at least get an interview,
I can prove myself.
And I just want to get that opportunity.
And instead of it being auto
rejected because I don't click
mark the box that says I
have a degree, you know.
If I get the opportunity I've always
been able to proceed but--
- Bro, then just reach out cold to the CEO
and tell him why you're not going out.
Dude, yes,
Yes, remember?
Yes.
- Okay.
- Tattoo that shit on your chest.
- Can I get a follow
on Instagram from you?
- NickZatta?
You got it.
- Yeah.
Thank you, Gary, for everything.
- You got it, brother.
All right, let's keep going.
- (laughing and clapping) Gary V.
Thank you so much, man.
Dude, I'm so excited.
- Glad to have you.
- Man.
Oh fuck. So I'll just get right into it.
I'm pretty sure we're
probably going to come back
to patients.
I feel that patients has been,
you know what I mean?
The slogan of the show at this point.
Even on the coattails of Nick,
like I'm four years out of grad school
but my question kind of
revolves out to like pushing,
like pushing through grief.
My first semester of grad school,
I lost my mom and that was
kind of like a huge thing.
Like I used it very much as my driver.
Like I used it to create that body of work
that was my master's thesis.
I write about her a lot.
I pretty much have like a
pretty fleshed out transcript
of poems that are like super grief heavy
but they're totally about her.
Friends of mine where my
birthday is always super close
to mother's day so like last week was just
like a fucking shit week just...
It weighs up like--
- Dude, it's one of the
most difficult events
in a human's life.
Even when they're 80, let
alone when they're at this age.
I'm so sorry you went through it.
My mom lost her mom at five
and I feared and my
dad lost his dad at 15.
And so my whole life, I
fear losing my parents.
And it was such a big
thing in our culture.
And people died very
early in the Soviet Union
And I just have a lot
of empathy for you, bro.
It's a real thing.
- Thank you.
And I've lived through it
with my dad and my godmother,
who is my aunt, where,
you know what I mean?
They lost their mom
when I was in undergrad.
So like I've kinda like seen
like the different stages
of it.
But it's completely different.
Like that just depending on like how you,
you know what I mean?
Like how you grew up.
Like my mom was the one who raised me,
my dad was working all the time.
Like he worked second
and third shift so like,
and then even when he was
home, he was still working.
So like I completely empathized with that.
But my mom was the one who raised me
and even though she was never
like my biggest cheerleader,
like I'm first generation
Filipino-American,
even when I would bring my
mom to like my art shows,
she would always be like,
"Why do you do stuff this way?
"Why is your work so dark?"
She would always like
question what I was doing
and I know like she would
support me like in perpetuity
but she was always just like,
you know what I mean?
Total chip.
And--
- Yeah, I didn't have that.
My grandma did that for me,
my dad's mom 'cause she was around a lot,
but my mom was like,
I would sneeze and my mom would be like,
"That's one of the great
sneezes of all time."
So I had the reverse of that a little bit.
- And shout out to my friend Becky,
it's her birthday today.
But one thing that she was
kinda like talking to me about
on my birthday was like you'll proceed
through this grief forever.
- Of course.
- And there's,
you know what I mean?
There are still gonna be
days that like hit you
like a Mac truck out of the blue.
There's nothing anybody
can really like say to you.
It's still just your pursuit of this thing
that is with you forever.
And there are just like sometimes that,
you know what I mean?
I try to not think about like if she is,
If hypothetically she is proud of me or--
- I'm with you bro, this is one
of the most difficult things Andy,
to get through.
But there is no time machines.
- Absolutely.
And that's like kind of
like the other thing,
like I feel that sometimes like,
even though like I'm
pushing like with my art
and I think it was earlier this week
where you were talking
about like dude sometimes
that w is going to kill you.
And like I sold like one big piece,
from my masters show.
And that was like the pretty
much like my biggest w as far
as like that part of my life and--
- How much did it sell for?
- It sold for four grand.
- Woo.
That's fucking gold.
- But you know what I mean?
It's constantly been trying
to, you know what I mean?
Still stay within like that.
Then now there's this
established market value and--
- It's a huge play.
And you know what I mean?
It's a play that can be made when,
you know what I mean?
You're showing in Boston
where that show was,
or like give your show in New York, but
I'm from like, I live in
New Bedford, Massachusetts.
And I love this community
so fucking much like
Kristen being Kristen,
like it's so much fun to like
watch and chop it up with.
I was chatting with Curtis
last night about just this.
And like Mike's dating show is super good.
Like dude, this community
that you have created
and that everybody is so dialed into
is just huge.
So like, thank you so much for this.
- Is there anything I'd help with?
Like are you just trying
to navigate the grief?
- That's essentially
where like, I'm sorry,
if I was a little all over the map.
- No, you didn't go all over the map.
You went to your truth.
I love your truth.
I'm all over the map 24/7.
Listen to me, the reality of this is this:
you had a mom that
brought you so much value
and you had her for 20
something years, right?
- Yeah.
And that 70, I would argue 50 to 70%
of people don't have mothers
that bring them value.
They brought them negative value.
Then with the remaining 20,
30 to 40% of people
that did have great moms
that brought them value,
or the other 25% of those people
lost their mom earlier than you did.
- Absolutely.
Like Daniel brought that up,
that he lost his mom's super early,
lost his grandmother super early.
And I was really hoping that
he was like going to dive into
it.
And then I was like (laughing)
- Yoh bro, what's that hat?
- It's a Rokkr hat, man.
- I appreciate you.
- This is what we do.
- Appreciate you so much.
Bro listen to me.
The reality is when I hear you talk,
you're coming from such a light.
It's funny when you
said your art is so dark
because you're dealing with
this darkness with light,
even the way--
The way you're communicating this heavy,
heavy hearted situation is
actually with enormous gratitude.
I can feel it under your words.
- Thank you.
Well, it's funny 'cause like I was kind
of just like front-loading my Instagram,
just in case like, you
know, hypothetically,
if Dustin was going to
bring it up on the show.
I just loaded like a whole
boatload of paintings up there.
- It's good, man.
Like I want to take a look at it
before I let you go here.
Bro, listen to me.
It's gonna be there forever
and it's gonna be better every single day.
- Thank you.
- That is the historic truth.
You know what I mean?
- And you know what I mean?
Like I'm on TikTok, I'm on--
- I'm your 518th.
Dude, this is huge.
This is so huge.
- You know this is about
to go to 1500, right?
- Oh man.
For what everybody
that's been on this show
like that has really taken this moment
that like it's immense.
For what it can do for us
and like what it can do for your--
- Whoa bro.
Your stuff is really interesting.
- Thank you so much.
- What's up with the
Magic The Gathering cards.
You got some?
- Dude I'm like flip life, baby.
Like it's what we're doing.
I just bought a box that
I'm going to do an
unboxing video on Twitch
and you know what I mean?
Like start flipping cards and like
that's been a huge part of my life.
I've been--
- Your food content's pretty good too.
- Thank you so much.
Like side note.
- Where are you on nutrition?
I see you work it out but
you got a little gut like me.
- Oh yeah dude.
Pandemic life has been
like pandemic 15 is hard.
(laughing)
- Pandemic 15 makes
freshman 15 seem amateur.
I'm with you on that one.
- Oh yeah, dude.
Especially like being in your 30s
you know what I mean?
It's all like you don't--
- You're not in your teens anymore.
Yeah, you're not a teenager no more.
That shit hits.
- Oh man.
But dude, like my mom,
like the biggest thing
that my mom gave to me
was learning how to cook and loving food.
So like I know that art was my passion
and so like I leaned into it.
I have a master's in painting
and you know like a boatload of debt
that goes along with that.
Like I thought that I was going
to be, you know what I mean?
Teaching college or whatever.
But that just didn't end
up being the route for me
and that's fine.
So you know what I mean?
- How much debt do you have?
Are you willing to share?
- Over 100K.
Like it is.
- I was going to try to get
the Vayner nation right
now to go and DM you
to buy all your art and take
you directly out of debt
but that's a fucking beast of a number.
- Dude, even getting on this show,
dude it's a war of attrition
and dude fucking patients.
I'm totally with it,
- Andy, this has been a great show
because you, the little man.
- Dude, little man like warmed my heart.
I was smiling so hard
'cause you know what I mean?
Especially like with his mom was like,
and then they're going
to go garage saling.
I'm like, I am immensely
appreciative of them.
- Listen to me.
I really think off the
springboard of this moment.
'Cause your art is real, real good.
- Thank you.
- I think there's a real shot
you can get out of debt in the next year.
Even with an economic slowdown.
I just think all your shit is
minimum $4,000 now, minimum.
And I think you can stunningly sell 25
to my community alone and be out.
I'm not kidding.
I think you're about to get
the weirdest DMs of your life.
- I'm with it.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm willing to, you know what I mean?
Drive everything everywhere.
- Andy, of course you're fucking with it.
Oh, wait with it.
If the beta (mumbles) pick you up
and it's offering you 5,000 a piece
and 20 of them sell.
No shit you're with it.
Dude I'm with it
if nobody asks me for anything right now,
you know what I mean?
- That's what's up man?
That I know.
That's exactly what I was going to say.
But listen, bro, you fucking won.
You know you won, you know you
got all the fucking pieces,
you had a fucking shit thing happen.
We all have shit things happen.
- Absolutely.
- That will be everyone's life to the end.
But you have so much blessings.
You have so much fucking
good, start fucking building.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- I love everything that
you're giving in perpetuity.
Dude I got the empathy tri-pack
because like I wanted to support you.
I dropped some money
onto all end challenge.
- Do me a favor, no more money for me
until rattle that hundo.
I mean it, no more.
- Absolutely.
- No more fucking hats,
no more fucking wine, no
more all in challenge.
Unless the raffle tickets
kind of cool if you won
- Well, you know what I mean?
Yours is done like that's all I was,
'cause believe me--
- Yeah, I get it.
Listen to me.
I appreciate it to no end,
but I need to get out of that hundo first
and then we'll get back to Wine Text
and other shit like that.
I really appreciate you, bro.
You've got a great heart.
I appreciate you, bro.
I really, really--
- Thank you so much.
- Listen, I really think
this was a special.
Dustin, this had like a sweetness.
This was like a sweet fucking show.
- Yeah.
- I mean I don't understand
how people don't understand.
Like this is like the fucking
sweetest place on earth.
- What don't you understand about that?
- That I'm fascinated by,
I'm trying to think about all the people
that misread me upfront--
- Oh, gotcha.
- that aren't taking
advantage of free content.
And then I'm not
understanding like I'm like,
"Fuck, who am I misreading?
"What am I misreading?"
Watch this stuff then in the comments.
Hey, everybody watching,
how many of you the first
one to two to three,
even four times that you saw
me or heard people talking
about me, thought I was a
complete con artist full of shit,
fuck this guy, charlatan, wait he's going
to sell me something at the end.
How many people?
Just say me,
me in the comments.
Watch this Dustin.
- Here they come.
- Look at that.
- Honestly, I didn't think that
when I first discovered you,
I really didn't.
Like, I don't know.
Maybe I'm naive.
- Or maybe your intuition is good.
Or maybe it was the
piece of content, right?
It all depends on what piece of content.
- True.
- He curses too much.
Somebody said, right?
Like that affects people.
Look at all these me.
- It's a couple of more mes.
- Ooh, it's a couple.
- No, some people in reverse, watch this.
Now, instead of me,
if the first piece of
content you were like,
"Oh my God"
Reply now and put my guy.
Reply my guy.
If right away you saw him
as like, this is my guy.
Let's see that.
- That's how I was.
But for me, I think it was just
because the first time I heard you,
you said you were from Edison, New Jersey.
And I was like, "Oh cool.
"Jersey guy."
(laughing)
What piece of con...
Do you remember the first
piece of content you saw?
- Yeah, April 3rd.
It was when you're on Elvis, Elvis Duran.
- (mumbles) you heard
it on the fucking radio?
- Yeah.
I was driving to work and I heard it
and I was like--
- Hold on Dustin, hold on.
You're telling me right now.
So wait.
When that piece of content
like, I don't know.
Have you ever worked with
that piece of content?
Or did we have any posts?
- Yeah, I always go back to it.
When I first started
working for you I always--
- That's the first day you were at Vayner.
Did you like...
You heard me on Elvis Duran
where I talked about
like, don't hate your job.
and then you literally
ended having a job with me?
- Yeah.
I didn't know that.
I mean I didn't like quit my
job the next day or anything,
but like I think then one
of my friends re-shared
like an old keynote on
Facebook and then I was
like, "Oh, it's that guy again."
And then it just went from there.
- And now you're a fucking
international superstar
(mumbles) fucking T-Community is upset.
You're more popular than I am.
- Yeah, right.
- I love you bro.
You got the Brogan piece?
- Oh yeah.
- So you can load it and
load in the Gary B2B thing?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
And we did the big Wine Texting today.
Premium wine.
Here's a good one.
If you want to buy a father's day gift,
we're selling a $70 wine
for like 33 bucks today.
32 bucks, 34 bucks.
So father's day gift, highly
recommend today's wine.
Your pops would go nuts
for two bottles of this,
if he's a wine drinker.
So thank you for all of my guys.
I appreciate all the people that said me
who persevered and came over.
So I really appreciate you guys.
I really appreciate you guys a lot.
Couple of things you're about to see,
you're going to put both of them
or you're just gonna do one?
- I can do both.
- Cool.
Actually just, you know, Gary B2B.
Just put up that right now.
We don't need to play that thing,
I think we played the Rogan piece.
'cause I think people
are gonna be blown away.
If you haven't heard it yesterday,
first of all, if you have Twitter sign up
for this right now, it's fucking amazing.
And then number two, we're
about to play you a clip.
I put on my Instagram yesterday
but not the full clip.
The team cut it a certain way.
But then later it came
out that it's reported
through somebody close to the sources
that it's a hundred million dollars
that Rogan got to go exclusive to Spotify.
Watch this.
Watch.
Big shout out to CK S Camilla.
She said she'll buy three
right now for a shout out.
Boom!
She's going back to buy three.
I sold three Brunello
already today Dustin.
This is me out.
If you follow me closely,
I've been talking about the
Rogan thing over and over and
over and over again.
But here's one clip where I even took it
to the next level and threw out a number.
I think it's gonna blow your mind.
Thanks everybody.
We'll see tomorrow.
Oh nice.
I like this.
Can we watch it together?
- Yeah.
- Attention always
eventually gets monetized.
When Joe Rogan inevitably
announces that he got paid
a hundred million dollars to
exclusively be on whatever pop
platform he's going to go on.
- I have an announcement.
The podcast is moving to Spotify.
It will become exclusive to Spotify.
- So I think when Rogan
inevitably does Howard Stern 2.0,
I think you'll start
seeing people realize,
"Oh, there is something here."
And I think people are very basic.
They look for a report or
a very simple ad product
to make them feel good
while underestimating,
when tens of millions of
people are paying attention to
something, inevitably there's
an opportunity to monetize.
Like I said in that clip,
the reason I knew is this
is how the world works.
Like you build up
traction in all platforms
and if you're at the tippy
top, like the Rogan is,
you then have the leverage
to go exclusive somewhere
and extract enormous dollars.
It's a big deal.
I guarantee you got a real real check.
Congrats Joe.
You worked hard for that.
For everybody else who's aspiring,
get into all platforms, get out there,
build leverage and then
reverse that leverage.